et je me trouve actuellement à
l'aéroport paris charles de gaulle au
terminal 2e là où se trouvent les
algériens bloqués depuis plusieurs jours
l'invité d'aller leur donner la parole
et voir dans quelle condition
bonjour a terminé à voilà je suis bloqué
depuis le 26 février et à l'aéroport de
roissy charles de gaulle celui-là même
si on voit tous les jours des orienteurs
france à descendre en algérie et avec
des étrangers avec une spéciale depuis
le 26 février
c'est ici que dorment les 25 passagers
dont des enfants des femmes âgées est un
homme atteint d'un cancer
mais les frangins finlande les
couvertures et a laissé d'organes aussi
quelques uns
ecully un dernier conflit perdure
et jamais elle routine qui dort sur ses
fauteuils tient à nous montrer aux doors
sa fille de 4 ans et une autre enfant ça
c'est pour les cuit
[Musique]
c'est bien qu'il soit venu ni de leur
passeport tests pcr et l'attestation de
rapatriement de l'ambassade d'algérie à
londres
air algérie leur refuse l'embarquement à
partir du 26 février le 1er mars
les vols de rapatriement sont suspendus
jusqu'au 31 mars en bout
on sait par deux fois on est une
situation qui a provoqué un élan de
solidarité et des anonymes fournissent
de la nourriture et à boire un soutien
primordial pour karine sandwich
s'organise au déficit est vraiment
difficile maintenant avec utiliser les
ressortissants exhorte le gouvernement
algérien à prendre rapidement des
mesures comme cette passagère tard quand
le monsieur le président vous avez dit
que vous ne laisserai jamais un algérien
se faire humilier à l'étranger
laissez-nous rentrer chez nous s'il vous
plaît c'est tout ce que l'on demande
monsieur kaboul contacté par rt france
l'ambassade d'algérie en france indique
que les ressortissants algériens avaient
été informés le 25 février de
l'annulation de leur billet avant qu'il
quitte le royaume uni une information
confirmée par zoé laouali représentant
d'air algérie en france mais démentie
par les passagers rencontrés je peux
vous envoyer des vidéos ont été informés
par du helmand mais il aurait été on a
fait notre mieux pour pouvoir dès public
est informé et il avait des attestations
de rapatriement pourquoi est-ce qu'ils
ont pas pu continuer leur chemin jusqu'à
alger
nous avons sollicité à nouveau
l'ambassade pour les attestations de
rapatriement en vain selon les passagers
bloqués ces derniers jours certains
algériens bénéficierez de passe droit et
aurait pu voyager pour motif impérieux
avec la compagnie air france de son côté
aéroports de paris affirme que cette
situation est du ressort des autorités
algériennes
ils sont en zone internationale dans une
salle d'embarquement ce n'est pas un
hôtel
nous essayons de tout faire nous avons
fourni des couvertures
nous avons aussi ouvert des douches s'il
faut faire des tests pcr rapidement nous
le ferons nous n'avons pas les leviers
pour agir sur cette situation
en attendant les frontières algériennes
sont fermés depuis le dit
7 mars 2020 depuis le 26 février aucune
proposition de rapatriement n'a été
proposée aux ressortissants algériens